good morning and landing is welcome back
to the morning toast happy Wednesday it
is hump day
make sure you hump someone real close to
you consensually of course I really hope
that on all these Wednesday's like you
have been humping Oh I mean I've Co so I
actually humped the oh so no he humps
you okay look this is gonna be something
I say that like it's gonna come back to
home like Shane Dawson yeah this is
gonna be something I was literally
thinking me as I was telling bed last
night like I was in one of those usually
like an hour before bed I'd become crazy
it's like a mile of 40 no reaches its
peak and I'm like running in the bed and
we're like we're like running around
like wrestling each other and literally
last minute I said to Ben and this is
gonna come back to haunt me I know it
but it's a joke okay I said two men I'm
like I don't know what to do like
sometimes like my love for Theo reaches
levels where like I don't know what to
do next like if I love Ben so much like
all six of them like I love to go so
much like I think I know it's like
that's when I'm with you and I feel like
that I'm like I feel like I have to eat
him yeah that it also works but now it's
taking on a manifestation where it's
like I just got to [ __ ] him got it so
you are an incest xual bestiality mother
mother
yeah yeah well happy Wednesday welcome
back to the morning tell us we have a
full slate of programming for you today
we got the Fast Five we are recapping
Real Housewives of Orange County and
watch out inside which was a great
episode me I got to meet Rick Leventhal
sitting in the Oprah chairs you could
tell he was like embarrassed no but like
he wasn't he wasn't and then I of course
had to like look at my phone Instagram
because as much as I know that he's Fox
News correspondent like I've never
really heard oh man if you didn't know
and he only broke up 500 times does he
have his own show on Fox News no I think
a Fox News correspondent would be like
if they had us come on daily pop every
now and then to like me the Taylor
Swift's like yeah okay that's like it's
like you're an expert in your field and
whenever they need you to speak on
something okay anyways we'll speak on
the whole episode everything that's
going down like it's really such a crazy
time in OC like this episode was nuts it
was but like I just can't like get over
the fact that they're at Key West like
it's so sad look think we all have some
Beverly Hills are in Rome before this
they were in Franz and like you know
what else is those here slumming it in
Key West
their behavior doesn't deserve to go
anywhere other
and agreed but some girl can't be like
embarrassing America legacy in Bravo for
the toast like I was just reading
people's thoughts on the episode this
girl was like oh we went here to this
hotel for my prom afterparty like
weekend that's where the real houses of
Oh si si well I mean there are there are
some really nice keys in the Key West
the shutter and they went there on
southern charm and like it looked fun
tonight like that it did have like those
kids on southern charm or kids like yeah
it's a perfect place for a bunch of kids
yeah much a place for like old women who
we're supposed to believe our affluent
even though we know they're not yeah
okay we will recap Oh see Heather Dubrow
would never have gone never have gotten
this maybe even Meghan King Edmonds
honestly knew she would go she's she's
really just ready to also yeah uh we'll
recap at the end we have a great show
for you today we actually have some
interesting stories and now we're
getting to the point in the year where
every like publication is doing their
roundups and as much as sometimes like
it's annoying sometimes I really enjoy
them like I love when I get my Spotify
end of the year round up like me - what
did I consume this year I'm gonna assume
that I consumed
I don't think telescope is gonna be on
there because I support artists who
believe in the artist right to own their
own music and I buy her albums so I
listen to them on Apple music so I think
I'll probably just get Luke combs and
Kacey Musgraves
yeah I think now this week I think I'm
gonna eat out in a Lady Antebellum win
because I have I can't Spotify last
night I saw you listening to a different
album golden
oh that came on after I went through
their whole first album you guys like
it's so good and it just brings me back
to those days and those were the days
those were the days that car ride where
when we were on vacation we took like an
hour drive to go snowmobiling and
Margot's phone was plugged into the
Bluetooth and she was only playing music
she had already downloaded on her phone
and that was like mostly Lady Antebellum
and it really like reinvigorated my
spirit of like my love for Lady
Antebellum and then last night I was
reading GQ did a roundup of the top ten
best country albums in the past decade
and Lady Antebellum need you now is on
there oh the album needs you now I have
any graduated to that album yet it's as
if Lady Antebellum just dropped a fresh
album because I'm listening to it on
repeat like love don't live here anymore
like and when I was singing it ten years
ago I didn't know what I was singing no
American honey you had no
I do you were talking about she grew up
on the side of the road no I had now I
know it's American camper right
also I'm that list very interesting was
read by Taylor Swift great album girl by
Maren Morris in Eric Church album Lou
Combs he this one's for you and number
one was oh it Chris Stapleton traveller
of course you know it's just I've never
listened to it I think I should because
I respect all the other albums on that
list and they're saying that albums
better than all those ones I gotta
listen I never listened to the song
traveler though like I never got into
Chris Stapleton oh he's really good I've
never gotten into him like beyond the
songs that are hits like strawberry wine
traveler I'm not even gotten into
strawberry wines like the same things I
love the song Chucky's that is Chris
Ableton's like mo Brent okay well I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a listen anyways
it's that time of the year where
everything's coming to a head but it's
also that time of the decade where the
decades ending schrutes the end of the
end it's the end of the decade but the
start of an age oh my god do you think
Taylor hopes is gonna do something on in
January because like she kind of has to
it was the end of a decade that's one of
her lyrics but the start of an age and I
was literally the end of a decade yeah
and I was gonna like wait to save that
as a caption for maybe my New Year's Eve
post but I thought I'd share with the
class anyone can use they should use
yeah just if I do just make sure to like
and comment and tag a friend yeah if you
don't use it it's up for grabs
no it's still anyone can use it look in
the family oh we could both use a barter
totally um there was one more thing I
wanted to say oh I got some really
interesting feedback about our podcasts
that I wanted to bring up because I
wanted to see if you agreed with it
because someone posted in our Facebook
group asking that we do something new
and all these comments were like yes SS
yes someone was like I guess four we'll
talk about something or someone for like
a long period of time and will only use
pronouns after we bring it up like we'll
be talking about Lady Antebellum and
then we'll keep referring to them as
they but people I guess I tune in and
out of podcasts and we should reiterate
who we're talking about like every few
minutes if we're going on for a while
cuz we're talking about a key hehehe and
people like rewind to like remember who
we're talking about
okay yeah okay if we're talking about
someone for a long stretch of time I
will try to remember to do that I
thought that was interesting feedback
one in which I'd never heard before
interesting feedback sure yes okay we'll
keep it in mind
well without further ado I think it's
time because I'm excited about the
stories today there's one that it's just
gonna break your heart so don't worry
it's at the end it's a little business
it's crazy there's news that breaks your
heart it's the saddest kind of business
but without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast and while it's
time for sure for sure for sure for sure
I would be so upset I would be like
remissed I would be devastated I would
even say heartbroken you can't have that
if I didn't let you know that today's
episode was brought to you by article
the easiest way to make your space look
beautiful
it's a direct-to-consumer furniture
company that combines the curation of a
boutique furniture store but the comfort
and simplicity of shopping online as the
end of November just happened so does
the biggest sale of the year keep your
eyes peeled and your Instagram open for
sneak peeks of articles forthcoming
Black Friday sale articles team of
designers focus on beautifully crafted
pieces quality materials and durable
construction they're dedicated to a
modern aesthetic of mid-century
Scandinavian industrial and bohemian
designs we ordered from article when
they first imported as a partner and I
was like shook at the the ease of having
furniture delivered because I don't
believe there's anything more annoying
than a waiting like eight weeks for a
couch and then like the coordination
like the guy calling you I'll be there
in 30 minutes India doesn't come for
four hours and you're like sitting or in
the air apartment that a couch like
waiting for this man to call you back
literally I would say I got this super
cute ottoman I think it was delivered in
two weeks and the guy called a second
here I'm like what okay come on like it
was so easy coming through come through
they have fast affordable shipping in
the US Canada and it's free on orders of
over 999 dollars plus additional
shipping for in-room delivery and
assembly assistance all in stock items
are delivered in two weeks or less
that's what I said they have super fair
prices you can save up to 30% on
traditional retail prices article is
able to keep their prices low by cutting
out the middleman and selling directly
to you they have no showrooms no
salespeople and no retail markups it's
30 days to make up your mind with simple
returns and exchanges plus the best part
is that articles offering our listeners
$50 off their first purchase of $100 or
more to claim visit article comm slash
toast and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout that's
article dot-com slash toast to get $50
off your first purchase of $100 or more
sign on get your home in order we are
ready for the Fast Five let's dive right
in let's dive right in first step
Spotify
has released the top songs artist
playlist podcast of 2019 and the decade
so let's start with 2019 are you ready
for this this means that our Spotify
emails are coming soon because they're
gathering all their tape they're
gathering their data so here's the news
for 2019 the top streamed artists were
post Malone Billy Eilish and ariana
grande of the year of this year makes
sense
top stream songs segorita a bad guy by
billy Eilish and sunflower my post
malloon which is like an amazing song I
contributed to a lot of those streets
can I see something about Billy Eilish
lesson I fell into like a Facebook watch
video whole like just there was somebody
and I ended up on the Howard Stern
Facebook page I guess they now have
performances did you know that like now
people come and like play piano like
super low-key like not like a full band
and I watch Lady Gaga perform a million
reasons and I think it might be her best
performance to date it was like so
inspiring you tell she wanted to impress
Howard coz like he's this impressive guy
and she just [ __ ] hit it out of the
park and then recently they had Billy
Eilish and filling a silas come and do a
song that I hadn't heard but like damn
she's talented this [ __ ] she's it yeah
um the top streamed album was Billy
Eilish when we all fall asleep where do
we go great question the top breakout
artists were lizzo lune a lil nas who's
Lou May I don't know but she broke out
or he I don't know thank you top
streamed podcasts the morning toast the
morning toast was number one then Joe
Budden's podcast was number two my
favorite murder it's number three and
good meat just hack it was number four
but that's so crazy they're like I had
never heard of any of the top three
mustard I've heard of my favorite murder
actually yes I have also but isn't it
crazy that like those I'm a podcaster
and I've never heard of the top three
Western podcast no totally and the top
podcast genre was comedy that's because
we remember well yeah that's not
surprising seeing as how we're driving
sales for Spotify totally the top stream
album not released in the past decade
was Bohemian Rhapsody by Queen that
makes a lot of so it makes a lot of
sense of the movie totally the most
active sign based on cosmic play little
jobs Scorpio so you uh-huh
I always forget like what people's like
signs are oh the top streamed kpop band
I wonder if you can guess this the
world's top moods based on streaming of
their mood themed playlists chill the
number-one mood was feel good
second was good that is good the second
mood was lit mmm third mood is relaxed
next mood is happy next mood is
confident interesting I never listened
to those mood playlists but I do listen
to mood with Lauren Elizabeth which is
dropping into episode today check it out
mood with Lauren Elizabeth on Apple
iTunes and Spotify totally okay and then
let's get into the best of the decade
shall we okay the most streamed artists
of the decade words one Drake to Ed
Sheeran three post Malone for ariana
grande 5 mm good for re forgetting there
were in the way middle I find it so
shocking that posts Malone is in there
like yes he's very popular I feel like
he's at the peak of his popularity now
so to be the most true artists in the
last 10 years it's kind of crazy
yeah um also a lot of people worship
that Taylor Swift wasn't in here but
let's me not forget she was on Spotify
up until four years ago because she took
a stand and then Eminem was the most
shocking because he hasn't released
music really yeah but I guess he has a
cult following and that's important and
that's valid that is the most streamed
female artists were ariana grande
Rihanna Taylor Swift SIA and Beyonce I
thought yeah yeah it was really shocking
do you include in your streams like
songs you've written for other people
because he has written many hits for
hang on say I don't think so okay that
would be interesting did you see see I
went to Walmart and they bought all
these people's holiday meals and nobody
knew she was yeah and she said that she
won the lottery and that's why she was
doing it and then they realized it was
SIA I [ __ ] love her and like not just
cuz she's close with the Kardashians but
I love that [ __ ] just shows her
character I think she's definitely like
the creative director maybe an
ambassador for Sunday service because
they use her songs a lot I'd change
lyrics to like Bible verses I think
she's just part of it because she's just
such a fan of the Kardashians because
she's a woman of taste that's the thing
she's definitely a woman of taste thank
you you know who loves her who Howard
Stern does he oh my god he's obsessed
with the song diamonds like we're like
diamonds in the sky the Rihanna song
that see a row she wrote it yes and
where she's obsessed with that song oh
my god I love SIA I think everyone
should watch her carpool karaoke it's so
telling it's so she's so talented like I
don't know whether to like you know
what's the word um compliment her on her
talents as a songwriter or a singer like
I don't know what she's better at like
she's so good at both
that album that she released most
recently with elastic heart chandelier
but like all the other hits alive alive
that was such a transformative album and
it doesn't get like the proper bird set
free accreditation is that the right
word yeah well it does because people
are streaming in and she's a number form
or stream female and then she made many
Ziggler famous like that's also an
important achievement oh and Candy Cane
Lane you know I heard another
interesting factoid that billboard I
think it was released they're like
Christmas songs of the century and there
was only one song from this sense for
the 2000s I believed like an original
song that made that list you know
underneath the tree by Kelly Clarkson
wow she's also just said you could song
and they chose it for host radio I'm
like I could work for billboard if you
guys haven't listened to our episode of
toast radio we are not doing it
quarterly and we did a holiday-themed
toast radio we mixed up some classics
with some new some originals and check
it out patreon.com slash morning you can
listen to it like up until and for me I
think the holidays really end on like
March first so you can listen to it up
to some member next episode of Joe's
radio you know exactly no you know what
I'm making a declaration about toast
radio because everyone loves it everyone
loves it and I think it should be an
every other month thing how do you feel
about that so we're gonna have one in
January for like a new year new you like
Brooke jams that will make you feel good
about like getting to the gym keeping
your resolutions yeah there are certain
songs that no matter what like make me
want to go for a jog and you want to
hear the weirdest one broken-hearted by
Carmen a something about the beats per
minute it's like perfect it's like I
have to be on the treadmill like yeah
get your banish but we started don't you
leave me brokenhearted tonight come on I
can just feel my arms like Josh you
don't I mean that's a great one song
maybe that'll be in my January book it
for the next episode of toast radio
patreon.com slash in morning coats and
the other interesting factoid some of
the Spotify data analysis um the most
streamed I like the decade ones that you
streamed
tracks of the decade
shape of you by ed sheeran is number one
not chalking one dance by Drake is
number two
and you know and I was gotta anesthesia
one dances so what song is that
oh that's one kiss yeah rock star
twenty-one savage and post Milan
interested closer Halsey in the
chainsmokers even though they made no
coin I need them blind about that okay
so that is like one of the most
interesting lines I've ever read that NT
data released a I think on Thanksgiving
he doesn't release where it was all
about the partnership between classified
a Black Friday all about the partnership
between Halsey in the chainsmokers like
when they had this song they wanted a
big voice on it and they were still kind
of unknown in the fact that they got
Halsey was a big deal so Halsey made
sure her lawyers gave her a good deal
she's like I'm gonna make these guys
huge stars I wanna my money and I guess
the chainsmokers they said in the blind
I didn't realize that this deal was
different from any other songs they'd
made with female artists and when the
time came they like didn't get money
because she took it all and now they
like hate her alleged yeah well no when
they were performing together on the
VMAs like touching each other's titties
like I definitely do not think they
hated each other maybe it was after that
they realized um and then the fifth song
is thinking out loud by Ed Sheeran Wow
hmm got two songs that's crazy how much
money to get your nose
thanks so much so much because like his
songs performed so well and he does like
huge Stadium tours yeah that's crazy
anyways hey just want to say thank you
to Spotify because it's an amazing
platform and I love it but I also I know
that all of these apps like steal our
data will not scale to give it to them
and they just like use it for nefarious
reasons but like thank you for using it
for a reason that's interesting giving
our data back to us yes fast I just find
this C fascinating and so if you're
gonna take my data that I've given to
you please just give me some insights
like this and I appreciate it and also
Spotify if you're watching like feel
free to put us on the home page you know
oh for sure yeah I know I couldn't your
analytics like most of the people that
sit on Apple that's on the homepage or
and if we ask them to yeah oh you have
to do by the way manifest destiny ask
believe receive what universe doesn't
know you want it unless you say the
problem that was like Spotify doesn't
really have such competitive like
podcast charts like iTunes has no so and
they only promote their own content like
three girls one Keith the Anna Schumer
podcast set like they literally have to
force her to do because she's so not
into it oh wait
so I am followed Amy Schumer on
Instagram like a year ago because I just
like had had enough it was just like was
in premium content at all and she was
pregnant and she wasn't sharing like for
me I just like wanted more pregnancy
stuff I actually went to her Instagram
last night just like to see what she was
up to and she has putting out so much
mommy content it's so [ __ ] funny like
she's back on her [ __ ] and I feel like
whatever she does next either it's like
a tour or a comedy special is gonna be
really funny like it's gonna be it's not
gonna be the same like [ __ ] jokes
like like now she's really getting like
she's definitely more relatable now yeah
she was like dead like reading one of
her baby books like it's not even a book
it's made out of cloth and she was
pretending it was in news but whatever
it was really funny like chera I'll take
it out okay and some more streaming news
Jaime's Streamy vibes jay-z has released
his entire catalog to Spotify for his
50th birthday I saw which is so crazy
because obviously he's a man of title
like he's very long he is title he is
title but not that I really care that
his musics on but someone posted the
toasters like watch the throne is now on
Spotify and it's so crazy that there was
a time in our lives where Kanye West and
jay-z put on an album and Beyonce was on
a song it's crazy crazy and also like
that album is really good it's really
good I'm glad that it's on Spotify I
mean it's like I feel like it's a kind
of a sad day for jay-z you know he's
turning 50 like and I'm sure he'll he'll
Bennett is like oh yeah I just wanted to
give my music to everyone but it's like
he just wanted people to hear his music
no it's so true and honestly is it
terrible that I didn't even know he
wasn't on Spotify no I wasn't sure
either but I'm really excited for my
husband who loves jay-z yeah I'm excited
for Liz hi but here's the thing like my
enema the side of her like my husband
loves jay-z but like I don't think that
he subscribed to title you know so thing
if he didn't like who was I just want to
know like when society is gonna come
together and just like acknowledge the
fact that title was like a big fat
[ __ ] failure and I appreciated the
the motivation behind it like it was an
important thing like Spotify does steal
from artists like I got the whole thing
but like it's a failure like we need to
all come together acknowledge that and
move on so we can finally just like stop
pretending like there's any people
listening on titles right and so all of
those artists who like are holding out
on Spotify just come to the party you
like it's great over here at Spotify and
it's great for that's like okay they
need it and they've worked out
they're artists thanks to Taylor Swift
like as a consumer and a fan of music
like it's a great platform and like the
music's for the fans so let's make the
grout a way to make it work ever
typically and I subscribe to Apple music
also and I just think that Apple music
is such a worse platform like they can
do what they want something about it
Spotify don't know if it's the fact that
like the interface is black like and
it's darker and like I like the green
elements like something about it is so
much easy to use so much more
aesthetically pleasing and Apple music
could never Apple music never and it
would end it will never but like and
like I still am buying my songs from 129
on iTunes when I want to I don't know
maybe I have like an old computer and an
old phone because I can still do it and
that's all I want to do with my life
meet you actually another think about it
I don't even think I subscribed to Apple
music I just buy music on iTunes and
listen to it on my music app on my phone
and I don't know the difference I don't
know the difference either and I don't
want to know
I love Spotify like I'm and those were
the days back in college when I got a
student discount if you don't know
you're a student get yourself a student
discount you just have to sign up with
your email and when I had to get rid of
my NYU email was like the saddest day of
my life
that's really sad I know we should get
like a family plan cuz I feel like we
might be saving money for all I like
doing my own thing over there yeah also
uh-oh so I would pay through the nose
for Spotify it's one of the most
important apps in my life what are the
apps were like if they like triple their
price to a point where it was like
unreasonable like stupid for you to pay
for it every month they would let go of
and what would you keep okay I'll do
what would I keep cuz it's not as hard I
would keep Spotify
I'll keep Amazon Prime oh no I wouldn't
are you a prime yeah I figured out that
I'm probably talked about this on the
show so I was like when do you start
paying for Prime and someone said it's
the anniversary of when you signed up
for Prime is when you get charged so
interested so it's not like summer so
it's not like a there's one month where
brunettes charge that means what I need
for crime uh no they don't too many
times where I've ordered things like
just in the nick of time and I need to
be eligible for two-day shipping got it
okay yeah no I'll just like going at it
I guess oh no I would never
um Netflix Netflix yes I would pay I
like having Netflix and even though like
sometimes there's nothing to watch like
there's a lot of stuff to watch yeah and
if I had to only do one of those plot
content thing yeah I would do Netflix
let them pay for Prime I get my prime TV
to also the hallmark movies now how much
is that
um it's pretty steep honestly it's a
couple bucks a month Tim yeah but tis
the season do you think you'll cancel it
after the season no no no I got a
support support my hallmark ease you
know one of the homework pans call it at
home keys they should call themselves
like though but that but the toaster
group for hallmark movies is mrs. Dimas
a movie miss Christmas big why did you
agree banks like no one was crazy about
the name but it's stuck
I like over our trip like really tried
to get into hallmark movies and I sat
down for three and I finished one and
like honestly I just can't with how dumb
they are what was that movie we watched
where the wedding the Christmas plan our
wedding yeah what was it called
something the wedding Christmas planner
I can't iterate how it was literally the
worst but it had all the makings of a
great movie right and like when that
girl ended up getting married look at
the end like thank you for joking
did you tell me they're pregnant no it
was so dumb it was like it turned into a
joke I just like I can't invest my time
into movies that don't take my time
seriously I understand it was so silly
and but that wasn't a hallmark movie
just want to say that doesn't come in
hallmark movies I think it was a
lifetime Christmas movie that was like
cuz hallmark movies are they don't get
married at the end they maybe get
engaged and then they flashed whittier
forward and they get married
I watched a lifetime Christmas movie
starring Mayim Bialik and it was just
not it
he was also incredibly silly seeing as
how she is Brenda herself as like the
Jewish actress like I know nothing about
my name Bialik except for the fact that
she's Jewish
and she's like very Jewish she's sneeze
should wear a skirt she covers her so
she's modest so like Barnaby's talking
to Christmas may be granted and the
maybe she played a half Catholic person
but like it was incredibly [ __ ]
stupid
it's insane two other apps that I would
pay for is facetune which they already
charged a lot I play facetune too it's
$25 a year yeah and Lightroom there's a
there's a free version and a version
that you pay for I do the version that
you pay for cuz it gives you just like
more stuff and they give you Photoshop
which I should probably learn how to use
oh um and then someone was saying and
then TMT patreon like I feel like no
matter how much that went up like I
would continue to pay for it on my dying
bet bread breath $10 to my name a tab it
is going to pay tab you wanna hear
something interesting cuz someone just
like sign up for patreon and they post
it on their story and when you sign up
for patron right now you get access to
139 passpo
which is like all of our episodes that
we've ever done and so if you if you're
not a patreon and you want to become one
like you get so much content I'm gonna
say a great gift it's the gift that
keeps on giving just just saying okay
are you ready for our next story and a
little bit more of of the year news
people reveals its people of the year I
saw which is apparently a thing that
they do
I mean it's most me now and this year
they just they couldn't get it down to
one so we have four people of the air
Jennifer Aniston Jennifer Lopez Michelle
Obama and Taylor Swift I'm gonna agree
on all fronts
except for Jennifer Aniston I don't feel
I said this was like a benchmark year
frankly oh yeah I'm I'm talking I'm
thinking decades and like no last decade
was more of her decade you know like
definitely Taylor Swift had a benchmark
here Michelle Obama her book is like one
of the highest grosser it's in every
[ __ ] Hudson news who was the
third person Jennifer Lopez Hustler's
like so much happen for her is she doing
the Super Bowl yeah right so like it's a
big year for her I totally understand
why she would be including this but like
what is really Jennifer Aniston Aniston
done except first star in that movie on
Netflix with Adam Sandler about the
murder on the yacht in the morning show
right now oh okay and I think she's just
in PR mode and like People magazine
would never give up the chance for an
exclusive with Jennifer Aniston I can't
believe Tyler Smith like posed for this
to me she's like so above people when in
Snitch posted to her story Taylor Swift
on the cover of People magazine saying
the year I found true joy quote I leaned
into who I really am like it was a
shocking thing to see because you can be
on the cover of People magazine and not
um have been a part of it like as a
tabloid like they see Yash's of you know
but to go to a photo shoot for People
magazine and to be like willing like
this is a collaboration and I just find
it shocking seeing as I should honor
actually he's so highbrow her at Vogue
she's on bogan People magazine in the
same league it's just crazy that means
she's really like churning out the press
I saw a commercial for cats last night
on TV and the song a beautiful ghost was
playing and I felt like really like I
saw the same commercial during real
house has a barn Charlie that must have
been what it was and I didn't
fast-forward through it too and I feel
like I enjoyed the commercial more than
I'll enjoy the movie I love that song I
didn't love it until I saw it last night
in this commercial dance with these
beautiful
yes beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful ghosts beautiful um anyways
yeah I'm here for I'm here for these
choices yeah I'm here for three out of
four of choices
oh not Jennifer Aniston pilots it's a
woman of the year people of the air they
do people of the year People magazine is
like so woke you know people in the
airspace that be alive they should be on
the cover of this magazine oh my god
they should they had a benchmark here
that's my favorite thing to say a
benchmark year do you feel as though
this was a benchmark year for you yes
because I got married and because I
started my passion project which is
presets jackie calm you and my sister
got to start her passion project which
is the team and Instagram and I served
in tik-tok have you posted I posted once
I feel her I haven't posted again
because I just haven't been cute but
maybe I'll do one today lesson I really
2,000 followers I'm pretty cool yeah
it's like kind of easy to get followers
on tik-tok because we're still in like
the beginning stage and I don't follow
anyone cuz we should I need you guys let
me know who should I follow you have to
follow Mark Cuban's daughter so she has
a tick tock that I stumbled upon she
gets her parents in it all the time like
Mark Cuban like wants to be with the
kids she's like this cute little girl
like she's like living the dream just
being like a natural billionaire flying
you know private to New York with her
best friends um but just hears sews
watch it like Mike is in it all the time
and she's like teaching is sir like tick
tock trends which I don't really know
about it but it's like certain things to
go viral and like certain dances and
songs and she gets her dad to like learn
the choreography and it's actually
really really cute and marking when that
seems like a great dad yeah he does I
also watched well she's young i watch i
watched Shark Tank last night definitely
under the guise of the ages which one
the holiday episode no I watch him on
CNBC so I think that's maybe a year
behind but I enjoy and it was definitely
new evergreen it was definitely an
episode because there were six sharks
Laurie and Barbara you can always tell
like how far the episode is cuz Laurie
I'm Barbara will look in titus how um
and the the brand was that beer tap like
portable beer tap oh it was genius like
everyone wanted these guys needed no
money they had already done like a
series a and they had but then Laurie
and Mark Cuban went in for a million
dollars each to do the entire
of a funding they each they give two
million dollars which was so crazy and
the guys they were being so rude to
these guys like they had an answer for
everything because their business was
profitable and Barbara Corcoran was like
I'm out you know you guys seem too good
to be true well like find out what's
wrong with them maybe they haven't
really bothers me about charting because
sometimes a shark will go out for a
reason that belief that they have where
another shark will be like no that's not
the case so okay come back it or no
Barbara was like I like your product I
just don't like you and these guys were
they young girls
old and these guys just like had they
had a good business like what why he has
to be feeling to go on Shark Tank isn't
it's supposed to be the opposite I guess
that they've they've been conditioned
like everyone comes who comes on it's
definitely like a liar and everything
they say is fake but like these guys and
the guy literally snapped he was like
they kept asking me questions I think
everybody watching him this guy was like
hey listen we weren't really hard to be
here let us get through our stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I was really glad that
he said that because no one was giving
this guy any respect because he was old
he wasn't like old like gray but he was
definitely 4050 yeah that's what I think
that's when it started the reason they
were so successful was because they're
the technology that they had built for
this like it was like this carbonated
pressurized system that takes beer from
a can pressurizes and carbonates it that
it's I guess when you come out of a tap
it's much better so if the technology
that they built they were both like
chemical engineers their whole careers
aid works like a GE type company so it
was like obvious that their products was
really good because they were both two
really smart guys and like no one was
giving them respect was really
frustrating that's really frustrating
but if a kid had made it oh man you know
it's like that kid there's always that
episode and they do human updates all
the time the bowties guy he's one of
them but it was like Walker Jim it's
like from like literally season two and
I think Daymond invested like 40 grand
for like 70% of the company it's like
we're doing $100,000 a year and it's
like it was the dumbest [ __ ] company
like nobody wants it and then there's
another company that would come on in
suing a hundred thousand dollars a year
and they're like you're only doing
$100,000 you're in the past 12 months
we've got 120,000 they're like oh why is
it bad I have no idea back in the day
like that was enough to get people's
attention on Shark Tank yeah
did she pay for their bridges too big to
fail okay are you ready for our next
story I don't know I feel like I want to
talk about how I got the Oh a dog DNA
test kit and it's the only thing I can
think about this days he just took a DNA
test
turns out he's
100% Russian even when he's fleeing
country so yeah he's got health problems
that's the puppy in him
bling-bling then he saw some fat the
doctor you could have had a bad [ __ ]
just a little helped you with your MD
just the embark dog DNA test kit is the
most comprehensive kit on the market
looking at over 250 breeds and 170
genetic health conditions to help you
best care for your dog so I did it with
Theo it's so easy they send you the box
you put it like a little q-tip in Theo's
little cheek pocket you put it in the
tube but you send it back they give you
postage and then literally like I
totally forgot about and then like a few
weeks later they just send me a text and
it was like Theo's dog DNA test kit is
ready and I was like so excited about it
obviously like I was looking for like
the exciting stuff like about his breed
and its background then it also does the
important stuff like health um it said
yeah they test for over 170 genetic
health conditions um it's the only
research grade dog DNA test kit on the
market they analyzed a hundred times
more genetic information than any other
dog DNA test and it means they're
scientists look at over 200,000 genetic
makers and can scientific and can make
scientific discoveries that will help
dogs have longer healthier lives and
that's all we really want while
competitors can get down to only 12% of
a breed mix detection and we're accurate
with down to a 5% breed component in a
mixed-breed dogs ancestry so Theo's like
breed thing wasn't super interesting
because he's a purebred he's a direct
descendant of all of his you know
ancestors both his parents were show
dogs so he was a hundred percent
Cavalier which made me feel good cuz
like I know it's terrible that I bought
him from a breeder but like I did pay a
premium price and I want to know at
least just confer like it was worth it
yeah adopted job um I say hypocritically
it's very easy to get started it's a
best-in-class dog DNA test kit its
number one highest rated by customers it
was developed by PhDs and veterinarians
for your dogs veterinarians for dogs and
you can know your dog's breed learn how
to best care for them um it's just
really important and then also it's a
super cute gift for like a crazy dog mom
like me like if someone had got me that
look that would have been a really cute
funny creative gift that over 100
percent and even I created even a crazy
dog and of course of course
um embark has an exclusive holiday offer
for you that you can't get anywhere else
go to embark vet calm now use the promo
code toast to save 15% off your dog DNA
test kit visit embark AMD
RK such a cute name embark vet VT comm
use the promo code toast to save again
that's embark vet comm promo code toast
a great gift for the dog mom ant or
father in your life sign on find where
your dog comes from write a song about
it smell amazing it's like honestly if
you don't know where your dog came from
how can you know where he's going wow
that's a beautiful sentiment
like truly I just got chills yeah people
who called chills and like goose bumps
goose pimples are disgusting are
disgusting and my [ __ ] husband had
the audacity to call them to his pimples
the other day so did you get a divorce
pretty much he also calls the burgers in
your eyes sleep and they put that to a
test on like a poll on Instagram and it
turns out everyone calls it that they're
called uh crises like eye boogers eye
crust USPS in your eye cookies mmm
cookies but they're called sleep like
everyone calls to that it was like
literally 99% of my Instagram poll and
usually when I'm like trying to prove
someone wrong on an Instagram poll like
it my followers never like to see me but
they fully deceived me that's that's
awful that's the worst thing I've heard
today are you ready for our next story
now
now that Theo took his DNA test turns
out he's a hundred percent Russian yeah
I think I'm thinking okay because this
is how Lionel Richie really feels about
Sophia Richie and Scott Disick's
relationship well he had said something
like a few years ago she wasn't getting
her inheritance
yep dating really shady but enews has
now spoken to a source and the source is
giving some specificities that's making
me feel like it's coming straight from
up one of their mounds while the Grammy
winner had his hesitations in the past
about the romance considering Sophia and
Scott's 15-year age difference a source
tells me news he's making quote more of
an effort with the flip it like Disick
star in fact Sophia 21 and Scott 36 less
do you not forget recently spent
Thanksgiving with the singer oh wow
Scott and Sophia are still together and
all is well for now the insider tells
these enews adding that Sophia is
infatuated with Scott they spent
Thanksgiving with Lionel Richie and they
all flew together on his private jet for
their holiday trips
Los Pinos Lionel has accepted their
relationship but still is an entirely
100% onboard
Scot mostly because of the age different
and how young Sophia is Lionel can see
how happy Sophia is though so he's
definitely making more of an effort with
Scott he's a really honest upfront kind
of guy and feels like his father
daughter relationship with Sophia is
more important than anything so he's
trying to be there for Sophia and to be
supportive of her despite his
reservations about her relationship
honestly he feels the exact same way
that we all do which is like we really
like this relationship it's the age
difference this is a little jar to some
your destructive in the beginning yeah
but now we're like all on board
accepting age difference is hard to
swallow so it's just a little bit of a
weird thing but we're here for it who is
Sophia Ritchie's mom mrs. Ritchie is it
like Lionel's wife's do I believe and
Nicole Richie is Sophia Richie's sister
but Nicole Richie was adopted yes
got it okay okay I know that I love
Lionel Richie I think him going on
American Idol was like one of the
greatest like PR moves like people
really got to know him it brought him
like kind of out of the Commodores age
like into the 21st century
I think he's so funny he's so personable
and you really recognize his talent and
he sits on the on the panel with like
Katy Perry who like takes nothing
seriously and like Luke Bryan who's just
like has his head in the clouds half the
time and he really anchors the show he's
definitely like the Simon Cowell but
he's very nice and really genuine and I
really like him
agreed and I'm glad that he's coming
around to Scott in Sofia and I
understand his hesitations for sure I
mean it's when Sharon's is crazy and
it's weird how like we used to talk
about them versus how we talk about them
now because like we ship them so hard we
like love that she's friends with Kylie
when like back in the day they were like
so many blinds about them and then we
thought they were really disruptive the
proof is in the pudding they've been
together almost two years now like
that's they I think they live together
there so a part of each other's lives
like she's friend then the girls have
accepted her smells like a cigarette is
Margo here Jojo snitch Jojo was like
someone's chain-smoking you smell that
smells like menthol you smell that yeah
you do right a little right someone's
toys want a cigarette
maybe it's the ghost of Sneetches past
lighting I don't think she's haunting us
um wait I had one more thing to say
about this Oh yesterday during the day
they were playing like rent um old
Kardashian episodes on E like when Kim
was blond is she only on one kid and
Lamar and Khloe were in the middle of
getting divorce and I Khloe like lived
with Rob because she didn't want to stay
in her sad house without Lamar
and oh and it was when Kourtney and
Scott were distilled skill still
together and honestly like I think part
of the reason why now we ship him and
Sophia is so hardest because he's so
happy and I think he was I don't even
think we realized I got the time he was
so [ __ ] miserable with Kourtney like
she was so mean to him like literally
she made him go to therapy and the
therapist like made him take up a hobby
like karate and like he just like didn't
take it seriously because like why does
that help your relationship like going
to karate classes with a bunch of
children like it was so stupid like she
was getting mad at him for not taking it
seriously and like I understood like how
in the hell would he [ __ ] take this
seriously right and also I think now
that we have seen more of Kourtney like
on her own at the time we felt like
Scott was the problem but now that we've
gotten to know Kourtney more for who she
is like we can understand why we thought
they sucked as a couple but then it
turns out Kourtney sucks and she's
probably sucking the life out of a
couple of like he loved her so much he
definitely loved her more than she loved
him he wanted to get married he was
always like talking he was a good dad
even though like he was sadly
problematic in Miami like punching the
thing and like definitely had problems
with this alcohol consumption like he
got his [ __ ] together and she's just
like she's miserable yeah and she made
them miserable and like when you're
watching these old episodes seeing where
he is now he's like obviously so happy
and like light almost and he was going
through all that stuff with his parents
it was just like a bad time hard times
man I'm happy that he's happy it's love
and love and Make A Wish
still justice for Gabrielle Union even
though it's everyone's speaking out on
her behalf and it's looking like it's
going well yeah and look part of the the
big issue here like it's like the fact
part of the win is that everyone's
talking about right and that Americans
not count like looks so bad Howard Stern
also said the funniest thing cuz he used
to be a judging who's like bless you
he was like they keep these men on they
get ugly or an older and they keep them
on for so long I mean like no offense
like how I'm endo like what I don't
understand really what he brings to the
table what is oh actually how do I tell
I was gonna say unless he came as far as
a stand-up comedian ya know but like
just he is a good judge just like all
them are but the women are like cycled
out like this cuz they want someone
younger and hotter that's what Howard
Stern says but the men can be as ugly
and old they say where did you hear him
say this um he said it on his show and
he was recapped
I read an article because I don't have
serious but like but I'm every time I
hear something about Howard Stern I'm
like inching more towards paying a
ninety nine no I know but a [ __ ] car
why would I write do it right and it's
like all they want to do is listen to
like old lady antebellum albums
I would never listen to talk radio you
know it's like if I have time so I put
my ear pods in and listen to something
like you know I'm jamming out to love
her I'm just like not yeah so I'm like
but maybe one day in my life like things
will change I'll have a long commute or
something ABB's like drop the kids at
school and maybe I'll learn how to tried
and so I will listen to Howard Stern I
think in order to drop your kids at
school you should learn I was actually
thinking about that last night for some
reason about taking my kids to school
and I was like I'm gonna be in the front
seat and then I was actually thinking
like do I tell my kids that Mommy can't
drive no they'll be scared I think also
it would probably be best if like we all
have children around the same time they
all want the same school so we do like
the carpool but then also I'm putting my
kids on the bus because we were bus kids
and like look how great we turned out
know also like kids who like are driven
to school every day been literally to
and from are so spoiled yeah
they are so entitled no you gotta get on
the bus and like the bus hierarchy you
learn a lot about life like life is like
a school bus really so true and like
those kids who like weren't experiencing
that and just so we're being chauffeured
to in front school every day like they
don't even they don't know real real
life and like every once in a while I'll
take my kid to school and like if they
miss the bus and it will be Street you
know hold on I was thinking about this
all last night as I was falling asleep I
don't know why I'm funny like when I'm
at bed and he told me that his mom jerk
from school every single day him and a
sister and picked them up I was like in
the city in the city which is like so
unheard of I was like this is a level of
privilege I cannot even really - totally
okay 15 - story it's a little business
with rot you buy our favorite business
brand vistaprint because if you want to
run a business you need vistaprint you
do and also like tis the season for
Vistaprint holiday card season like you
gotta get on it so you know we love this
support we made our business cards on
vistaprint but now that it's the holiday
season and you're one of those people
who like has their life together and
takes a family picture but like you your
husband and your dog and you want to
send out holiday cards you've gots
together mister print whatever reaction
you're looking for this holiday season
you can spread more joy with custom
holiday cards calendars and photo gifts
for mister print calendar is also really
cute gift for your husband like maybe
like a sexy that boudoir photo shoot no
matter where you'll be during your time
off whether it's skiing hanging out at
the beach settling in home with your
loved ones and nothing says happy
holidays like custom cards calendars and
photo gifts from mr. print when you open
a car door calendar and you see your
friends family even dogs smiling
you it just feels like a special time of
year it also feels like the person cares
because they put time and thought into
making it but guess what it doesn't
actually take that much time at all here
all you have to do is to create a custom
holiday card pick a shape like a square
rounded corners fold it or flat then
choose one of vista prints designs
gorgeous eye catching looks next time
next you can put your favorite picture
right there and most of the options even
upload a great shot right from your
phone then just figure out how many you
need and order them time to spare they
told me the most hard part like who gets
one you know like who special enough
like if I were sending holiday cards
seeing as how I have so few friends I
probably knew that come into my Mordor
like 10 yeah um you can they have
hundreds of card designs from timeless
classics to fund new trends they have a
custom calendar as a gift that keeps on
giving all year round all custom cards
and calendars are up to 50% off right
now you can also upload your favorite
photos right from your phone and save on
mugs canvases and other photo gifts your
satisfaction is 100% guaranteed
or they'll make it right either by
reprinting your order or offering a
refund so this season make Amer make
merry at Vistaprint comm with up to 50%
off all holiday cards and photo
calendars plus great deals on photo
gifts at vistaprint.com just make sure
you enter the promo code toast 50 that's
vistaprint.com promo code toast 5-0 the
offer expires January 5th so it's more
than enough time make sure you head to
vistaprint.com the promo code is toast
500 sign on and get lit for the holidays
get lit for the holidays also people are
talking about their experiences taking
the bus and someone said the most like
true thing ever
Zach yeah do a Rolla I got driven to
school on days I had a project too big
for the bus
but I guess diorama yeah or like the
data poster for the pies they're
dangerous yeah you know what like you
worked so hard on your science fair
project like the least you can do is get
driven to school also like if you were
in the car I don't know cuz like we were
really never driven just cool but like
you can't sleep in a car just like the
radios on you're talking to your mom
like in the bus like you had the best 45
minutes leave them your life and then
you open your eyes a little bit oh we're
still not there I go back to sleep no
totally maybe that's why now I can fall
asleep anywhere like on planes because
yes I took your head against that cold
glass the answer is evening more yeah
totally totally also I feel like when
you did the only time you got you into
school was when you miss the bus and you
had a pit of
yeah what's it like going on feeling or
not like top down like hands up in the
air you're like oh my god no totally and
then I watch all these shows like big
little lies and like they're all driving
their kids to school like where's the
bus where is the bus or bus is a thing
of the past
no I mean you still see them in the
streets the kids look so miserable Mike
yep that's a rite of passage sir it
really is and like one day you'll be old
enough to be the oldest kid on the bus
and like you can claim ever on snacks if
you so choose yeah but I think you learn
a lot about life on the school bus fifth
and final story biz news sad news
America braces for a possible french
fries shortage after a poor potato
harvest it's a potato famine it's it's
happening all over again
potato processors are rushing to buy
supplies and ship them across northern
Russia like Theo they are in order to
keep french fries on the menu after cold
wet weather damaged crops in key
producers in the US and Canada ho yes as
cool conditions started to hit growing
regions in October lashing potatoes with
frost lashing lashed potatoes farmers in
Alberta and Idaho were able to dig up
some damaged crops for storage brook
growers and Manitoba North Dakota and
Minnesota received snow and rain forcing
them to abandon some supplies in the
fields don't mean someone wrote the
funny thing about to us really slash
growing up in Florida taking the bus was
basically going into a sauna I thought
about that in New York the morning so it
was mostly so cold it was so cold known
you were like junior hockey players with
your mittens yep and then had took them
on the whole time the Hat right and then
kinda mins ahead of string so you could
put them in your coach didn't leave Kim
Kardashian's Instagram story we're like
I guess good Americans sent out this
like PR kit that I obviously didn't get
and it was like full of like winter
necessities and I had those gloves you
know they're mittens but then you could
take the mittens over your fingers and
it turns I get two little gloves with
your fingers Kim was like she I guess
she had never seen it before cuz she
like grew up a whole level another level
of privilege like that [ __ ] did not
take the bus and whether privilege right
and she like never saw that there was
like gloves that were also mittens she
was like look at this technology like
she couldn't get over it's like [ __ ] we
were all wearing those in the third day
and you know I think those gloves even
though yes you can use your phone like
they make your hands so cold I just
rather not text my friend okay and also
be running the bus before there were
phones thank god we've gotten so
nauseous totally know there was real
nothing to do except like on the way
home like maybe you would conversate
with other kids but like definitely on
the way there to school like you were
sleeping silent and I was listening to
my iPad who I was listening to panic at
the disco I remember pulling up to the
school you know what's so funny but I
think we all had iPods like there was no
iTunes like that I mean weren't paying
$0.99 for a song we'd have any money so
we were downloaded illegally Nymeyer um
and there are still some songs that I
hear that I I listened to so much and
they had like weird like overlays in
them so it's like the song who's first
John Mayer just listen to her on the bus
and I still remember who says I can't
get its own turn off the lights and the
telephone me and my house alone who says
I can't get stoned John Mayer but it was
all pirated music and it had like weird
vocals in it just like because it was
burned
that's so funny sometimes I think those
scenes was talking like why do I know
John Mayer taught Tom like it was so
funny that's in this concert I was
literally like John Mayer comic it's so
ingrained in your brain wow that's crazy
okay sorry back to the potato famine
back to the potato game you know it's
kind of sad like obviously for me is
like a fat person but also like for the
primary performers like yeah like this
is their livelihood ya know it's sad for
everyone Donald's and like fast food is
like not made of real potatoes it's like
chemicals I think they're like they use
like at least one potato four thousand
cries you know that's terrible yeah it's
just sad so just be conscious of that
and maybe find like an alternate I
wonder how sweet potatoes are doing or
maybe they're made from potatoes no
those are sweet potatoes
I hate sweet potatoes like it's sweet
potato fries like people who are like
yeah I'm like they're not the same no
they're really really good but like
they're not healthy so why not just eat
a fry yeah you know um okay let's recap
the Real Housewives of Orange County
they took their trip to Key West I don't
understand the logistics of the trip why
did they stay in Miami for a night I
mean that was just like how Bronwen saw
it they should have stayed for like a
few days or the whole time I think they
actually would have loved Miami them at
11:00 was so funny in Tamara showing up
in the keys wearing an 11 baseball hat
11 is the best [ __ ] Club in the
world I talk about it literally all the
time and
it's like a strip club that's open 24/7
but then from the hours of like 11:00 to
like 4:00 a.m. it's like a nightclub but
it's still a strip club it's best I
agree also this was they flew from LA to
Miami and then went to the club like
Bremen are you a torturer and then woke
up and drove three hours insane
I don't know how these women do it like
I'm they don't kelly throwing up at the
Maserati oh my god totally and then she
said I'm on a tribe inside that she got
into the production man but like she
should have been sitting in the front
seat when that by the way and the fact
that Jeana didn't offer her to switch
because Kylie was like I cannot be in
this car anymore Jeana was like so
selfish but maybe she was just hungover
maybe yo maybe not carsick yes
necessarily I've thrown up in a car from
being hungover on the way back from
visiting my friend Hana at Babson it was
literally the most disgusting thing ever
like I throw up in the chair I can
everyone was like oh my shot up I'm sick
it's so so so much better though oh of
course and I just think we're gonna
Rachel's jacket to the dry cleaning cuz
I got like a little Bobbitt on the dead
I'm like the black just wash it off be
cool well um I agreed like this trip was
truly treacherous but like they were
literally acting like 21 year olds like
when they were going in and out of the
bars in Key West I was like who are
these people like Vicki Tamra's a
grandma vicki is almost 60 you like come
on it's crazy
she took a family there honestly I so
respected and I couldn't I just hope
that like I am able to do these things
when I'm their age you know I said I
compared they do them at my age um
they're basically on two separate trips
and I'm surprised that it's not more of
a conversation like um it's like not fun
like they they're splitting up the whole
time they keep splitting up the same
exact way and some franchises they at
least mix it up a little bit like it's
literally the tres tres amigos and Jeana
was like so transparent on the the most
recent night where she wanted to out to
dinner at them she was like Emily she's
like I just feel like it's bad if I can
were both here like I'll go with the
Tres Amiga it's like literally nobody
thought oh no I understood what she was
doing and I know that she just want so
wanted to be with them but then it makes
the divide more of a division if it's
them and us so mixing in people is good
um
vicki was out of control she was out of
control I really feel for Kelly meet you
they the double standard between like
how Kelly acts and how all the other
women act was never more apparent than
it was last night like Vicki was [ __ ]
crazy that first night at the bar not
only was she wrong because and everyone
was telling her she's wrong you
shouldn't be communicating with the girl
with the hand she overreacted Kelly was
so composed like I was so proud of her
so like she's a stat then she was like
conwoman if I'm like it was so funny
Vicki lost her [ __ ]
nobody said anything the next day Kelly
lost her [ __ ] and called linky a pig and
ever the Kelly you lied
whereas like Vickie was calling her a
[ __ ] the night before right also like
Kelly's called Vicki a pig so many times
it's like when it's the same insult I
don't know it's just everyone's like oh
that's where we draw the line meanwhile
you can contact a girl who's suing you
you can jump on this but you can say but
no Pig no yeah no it's like there isn't
lovely there was a different set of
rules and what I really liked about box
trap inside last night it was that that
guest who was like an actress who's been
an everything and I couldn't remember it
she was in um she is a huge OC fan and
she's super she didn't like a really
smart woman like she's wise and she's
very like illogical and she also really
felt like everyone was making a
different set of worlds for Kelli like
yeah and I liked that Kelli was getting
that support and it felt genuine yeah
and so when it comes to Kelli Tamra and
Shannon it's actually really frustrating
because we as a people lost out on this
season because that video was leaked and
now the seasons going in a direction
that it wasn't supposed to and I
actually think it was a toaster who did
that he only blows and I'm torn because
I'm the one hand like we want the
premium content all the time in the
group we want the tea on the ground but
on the other hand it's like it derailed
this season because it took away from
what Kelly and Tamara should have been
fighting about which was Tamara bringing
up Trey and Tamara like doing all these
snide things when the one that she won
the thing that Kelly is most mad about
isn't actually what happened and why is
Jeana and why do chena and Shannon keep
saying like Kelly you're reacting Tamara
was actually the one defending you she
really hasn't been defending Kelly she's
just been bringing up everything Kelly
like is doing behind the scenes yeah any
time it's brought up it's from Tamara
but when we see it we see it that way
but I think Tamara act has been acting
like she's a Kelly supporter you know
yeah well when Tamara came here and said
she has no idea why Kelly like his mad
at her like I think give you a few ideas
like right not that complex right so
anyways that footage being leaked really
just derailed what they were on their
their way to like having a real fight
about a real thing that Tamara was doing
and now it's just all gotten crazy plus
then now Kelly's in the wrong because
she brought up the lawsuit in gym
and yeah no that's that's totally below
the belt came over like we can't even
talk about it
totally so it's it's kind of annoying
Emily was like basically non-existent in
this episode and so it was broad win I
just want to say once again because I
have to you know say my love louder and
stronger than I said my hate
I'm loving Bronwyn me too I mean she's
she friends that's a good friend and you
know what's did you see the clip for
next week where she's on the bow and it
looks like she's talking [ __ ] with Tamra
and Vicki yes what Bronwyn is doing and
I would do the same thing in her
position and I think she thinks she's
making things better when she talks
about Kelly and she talked about the
fight with Brian and the kid was there
she's telling the story not to be
gossipy but to defuse it and be like no
no this is what happened it's a very
normal scenario we got into a fight we
left the party the kid left like and
then when she's on the boat and Tamra
and Vicki are saying terrible things
next week's episode was a preview of
March at happens live she tells the
story of what happened in a in a very
normal way but it looks like she's
talking [ __ ] it appears to be gossip but
it's just like a spreading of
information because like sometimes when
you're just like oh if he/she was like
don't say that that's rude she looks
like she's finally defending today
instead she's having a conversation and
the dialogue where she's just being like
no this is what happened like these are
just the facts and so I feel like to
Kelly it would look like she's talking
[ __ ] but I think she has a different way
of going about it and it's actually
exactly what I would do and like what I
probably done in New Jersey a lot too
where it's like you're friends with
someone who everyone in the group is now
talking [ __ ] about and it's so
uncomfortable and like there's really no
way to handle that properly because if
you say like stop talking about my
friend there I go [ __ ] you yeah and you
sound just like either and blind defense
of them um also I'm very excited for
this new episode of Real Housewives of
New Jersey because I just caught up on
though the most recent episode and
Jennifer just being like Dolores said
that she did think you mean Jackie were
friends I was like excuse me yes
shucks like that was really not okay it
wasn't okay but it was just said and
Jackie's you know instead of we have to
talk about it the reunion in five months
you know let's just deal with it now
yeah and I do you think it was so crazy
like they're really not friends I
couldn't think of two people who are
actually more different or more distant
in the group well I think there's a big
difference and what Jackie probably
doesn't understand between someone
liking you we get along versus I
consider you a friend and I think to
Dolores the word friend means like
family you know and so come over to your
house I don't know what Jackie thought
that they had
they probably do have but it's just what
not do worse doesn't define that as a
friendship I'm it was in this episode
where I kind of like really opened my
eyes to what I don't like about Jackie
and like I know that I should because
for the most part she's very logical
like she doesn't say really like mean
things she doesn't say untrue things and
I know you don't like her but I she's
not my favorite person personality wise
but I like her because she says the
truth and what everyone at home is
thinking you know and it's like I think
she gets punished for that and it's just
it's annoying yes so I think I now
realize what I don't like about her has
nothing to do with what she says like
what she says is fine yeah that's what
people thinking like I don't really like
give that much thought to what she says
I think that she claims to be like so
like certain of herself and like she
doesn't care what anyone thinks but
she's like so crazy sensitive like and
she takes umbrage with what like she
doesn't let anything just like roll off
her back like if you're a house but you
can't pick every fight as your fight but
like she does like or you or you just
have to be the sensitive one right and
not the lawyer ballbuster yeah right
right that's what it is it's like you're
looking really sensitive even though you
came on being like I don't care what
anyone thinks I'm a lawyer like and the
fact that she was like now taking on
which is what Frank said about her it's
like oh my god all he said was that she
was a lawyer right and then it's like
but you wrote an article about
Jennifer's house and like to me that's
still really strange to me it's one of
the most [ __ ] up leave is everything
she wrote was nice to a tee I think
writing about someone without their
permission he's a weird thing to do and
rude rating that's almost kids too it's
just the whole thing was weird to me I
bet I do I do like her I like what she
brings to the show because she just says
what we're all at home thinking and I
understand why none of the women can say
it or why they didn't want to say it but
it's like it's in no it's frustrating
when it's like it's the elephant in the
room like it who throw your husband
would he be in jail she's the only one
who even responds to Therese said
sometimes Therese is so unreasonable
like as a me where he'd get frustrated I
totally get that
that doesn't weigh how annoying she is
to me the other thing and like and
Theresa in those pictures with that
young guy and everyone's being like oh
she said the time that they're it's not
an affair and Jackie did say it's an
affair she said it looks like an affair
yeah it might be an affair her birthday
party yes I want to talk to you about
what it Amazon box like I get that she's
a cool mom who doesn't care I'm like
that was so evident but like you're on
TV like put together something well
here's chair here's what I think she was
doing like I
understand the mentality of this is a
kid's birthday party they just want to
have fun it doesn't she's being the anti
Taylor Armstrong who spent over a
hundred thousand dollars on her kids
like 5th birthday party and she wants to
be like that that cool parent who's just
like down-to-earth and it's about the
kids and they don't need much and I
actually understand that mentality
because you don't need to spend so much
but like the like playing basketball in
the front yard it's not a nice a Friday
afternoon at Jennifer's house like
there's a there's some middle ground in
between that party and at Party of China
first by the way when she was explaining
like the party I thought it was for sure
I kind of agreed like you can have a
nice party at your house with like some
balloons a cake a bunch of tables maybe
like a bottle of wine for the parents
and that's just very low-key but like
literally like the Amazon box she was
like going out of her way to show how
little she wants to put into this party
and it's like you can give gift fat you
can give giveaways not like in bags with
tushy papers just leave them out on the
table but like them coming out of the
box it's just really weird also makes
like more work for you yeah it was all
the trash and I felt like she was being
intentional now because that's the kind
of like housewife she want like real
housewife she wants to be but you're on
a show about like affluent people like
you got to put in a little effort no but
it's not about the appellant's like she
just wants me guess I can afford to put
on a party but I don't think that it's
something that I need to do and I'm
gonna go out of my way to show you how
unnecessary it is gotta see her doing
that I would have if I hadn't seen the
episode I've been like actually I'm here
for her not spending that much but in
seeing it I was like oh no no these kids
they want to go inside like they need
one another just one other activity even
if it was like a balloon artist if
employed really anything also like it's
it's not even about the money because
she bought the gift bags but like it
would have cost her no more money to lay
that out yeah so it's like she spend the
money but didn't give a [ __ ] it was
really sad yeah she just like really
wanted to be like the cool housewife who
didn't give a [ __ ]
and at first I understood where she was
going with it but then it didn't land
because the kids were like sweaty and
crying and like bored yeah
so they needed like an indoor activity
they needed something yeah there should
be an indoor outdoor option for all
parties I think that's like good for
everyone to think about um also I just
love Jennifer I just really do I love
her and I just need I need everyone to
love her as much as I do anything like
and the division is like so clear in the
garden and I just like I wish Jennifer
was on
I know also one more thing I wanted to
talk about was how everyone was kind of
talking about how Jackie didn't like eat
all day and then she said sounded and I
was like I haven't stopped eating yeah
at first I was like kind of it was kind
of hit me wrong when they were talking
about her eating like because some was
just like Oh Jackie he's not gonna eat
that but then they were just like
talking about how she's so regimented in
her life and how they can't relate to
that it's not just about eating it's
about you know who comes to her house
and the way she is and I understood for
the first time why someone like Dolores
wouldn't like that's not Dolores is PETA
Flores is like a big pasta everyone come
over yeah exactly so it was interesting
but then when they were all just like
talking about her it just made me
uncomfortable like this she's a nice
girl yeah it was weird
so the reason why I bring that up was I
saw a tweet and I cannot verify whether
it was real or not but you know Jennifer
just got liposuction and Jackie
basically tweeted and was like um if you
watch what you ate you wouldn't need to
get liposuction every other day which is
like so not cool but then I went on
Twitter to find it and I couldn't find
it so either she deleted it or was fake
I don't know if I don't want to say that
it was a hundred percent if it wasn't
but it does sound like something she
would say and that was not cool cuz I
think Jennifer looks amazing and
Jennifer did lose weight and now she's
getting away for some [ __ ] like confirm
no and also do whatever the [ __ ] you
want it's your like it's your body yeah
it's your choice I thought that was like
so that really like turns me 100% on
Johnny that's true and you know and I'm
gonna give her the benefit of the doubt
yeah there's my investigation and I
actually I actually don't think that's
something she would say so I would be
shocked yeah because I think she's like
more about and that's what she has
spoken about how she is a survivor of an
eating disorder so like someone who was
wouldn't judge others for their choices
so I'm gonna reserve judgment if anyone
can prove the veracity let us know thank
you guys so much for watching the
morning trust the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we have
merch dropping this Friday at 1:00 p.m.
Eastern Time so la people you are set up
real nice mhm there's a new episode of
mood with Lauren Elizabeth dropping
today there's a new episode this snacks
are dropping tomorrow where olivia is
joining Margot and I believe there was a
new episode of date night with Raven and
Adam dropped on Monday so check it out
there's tons of content if you need more
of the morning just pay Chyna's
patreon.com/scishow morning shows you
get access to over a hundred episodes
thank you so much for watching we love
you we will see you tomorrow have a
great day everyone
you
you